salut aujourd'hui je vais recevoir un
potentiel à jean benjamin verrecchia qui
va potentiellement partir pour sa
première mission je vais lui faire
passer une série d'épreuves je vais
essayer d'extraire des informations
sensibles caché à l'intérieur de son
cerveau avec des techniques de
mentalisme ceci est réel ceci n'est pas
une fiction
avant de commencer sachez que le
partenaire de cette vidéo n'est autre
que prime vidéo dont l'objectif est de
vous faire découvrir l'univers de totem
la dernière pépite de ce service de
vidéo à la demande totem c'est une série
d'espionnage qui met en avant des
personnes ordinaires qui se retrouvent
dans des situations extraordinaires et
qui vont les obliger à sortir de leur
zone de confort on est tout simplement
plongé dans les années 60 en pleine
guerre froide et sous des aspects de
monsieur ou madame tout le monde les
personnages de la série vont devoir se
transcender pour faire face à une
situation et à des ennemis qu'ils n'ont
pas l'habitude de rencontrer de leur
quotidien c'est aussi une série où le
suspense est omniprésent de par les
enjeux stratégiques et géopolitiques
raconter et à travers le triangle
amoureux qui existe entre plusieurs
personnages francis ané doubina mais je
veux pas vous spoiler plus si vous êtes
intéressé par la série sachez que vous
avez toutes les informations dans la
description et que vous pouvez la
retrouver dès à présent sur prague vidéo
d'ailleurs à la fin de cette vidéo vous
pourrez aussi découvrir quelques
extraits de la série pour que vous
puissiez voir le mood et comprendre un
peu ce qu'on a tenté de reproduire
aujourd'hui à notre petite échelle j'en
profite pour remercier prat une vidéo de
nous avoir donné l'opportunité de
tourner cette vidéo là dans ces décors
là aujourd'hui vous allez voir ça va
être incroyable gaspiller vos
[Musique]
benjamin et moi partir de maintenant ça
sera à jambes et très bien à jour des
neuf mis au dépôt à jambes et merci
beaucoup ça me fait plaisir on est là
pour construire ta mission
tantôt thème ta nouvelle identité si tu
préfères d'accord et si j'aimais bien la
première on tue l'oubli d'accord
bon je réponds seul interlocuteur jetons
agents disent on retient juste ça a
grimpé à grimper oui c'est bon pour toi
oui c'est une lettre de l'alphabet je
pense qu'on sortir exempté quoi on va te
faire passer un petit test c'est l'agent
au qui va te recevoir d'accord mais
avant on va construire son totem est
bien très bien
[Musique]
agent ben
oui à jean jean
j'en paie agents payés par dont je
connais ma mémoire excusez moi bon
écoute tiens je te confie tout de suite
les instructions
pour ta mission
gare de l'est sur toi très bien je
prends une cachette dans la poche hyper
important ne les paiera bien sûr je ne
sais dans la popoche bon comme je t'ai
expliqué on doit créer une nouvelle
identité je te laisse le choix j'ai le
relais lire avant bien sûr
l'interrogation alors yeux du choix
entre où là c'est nicolas et titoff est
un très bon humoriste j'ai également le
choix avec dimitri allez y est
[Musique]
alexei petrov alex jany alexis avec ses
petrov c'est petit c'est pas mal
et françaises qui me colle à la peau
voici les cotes
je vais aller sur alexei petrov je
trouve que ça claque c'est pour moi ok
alexei petrov
n'entre pas ça serait intéressant aussi
que tu choisi une profession ok ok un
truc où tu te sens à l'aise footballeur
international peut-être champion du
monde tu sais jouer au football non
alors arrête les blagues citant pardon
concentre toi tu peux être poète avocat
commerçant choisit un truc qui
cgt et bénisse et bénisse c'est parfait
j'allais être et bénisse alexei
l'ébéniste c'est d'ébéniste pense aussi
à un nom russe dennis tu le paies de
lait d'ânesse ici mais quand on choisit
son totem on choisit toujours un petit
accessoire fétiche d'accord une
signature très très bien
première signature un stylo est en fait
anti micro porté 25 m très bien très
bien qu'ils internet bien sûr bon ça
ce serait pas un fil électrique avec la
vie non d'accord
ok pourquoi pas c'est intéressant
briquet appareil photo très bien chez
moi ton plus beau sourire un peu dans la
boîte ok non j'aime faire avoir parce
qu'on va tout de suite on va me proposer
une cigarette je vais dire un non on
vient là pour coter imbriquées non très
bonne réflexion
d'un simple pièce
j'imagine que non c'est du chocolat
alors ça contient du seigneur pour
[ __ ] si ça te laisse pas les doigts
après ça assez bon ça j'aime bien ok
très utile de power émission en faire
disparaître les gens bien sûr dernier
accessoire poil plus commode
à vous d'accord le livre bombe c'est
quasi de l'ordre de la machine à laver
quoi c'est un peu con tinue puis si tu
prends ça je t'expliquerai commenceront
dès tout ça deux charges avec ça tu fais
péter tout un bureau non je vais dans la
non-violence et moi que je suis un agent
qui est plus dans l'analyse et
l'observation je prends lentilles micro
comme ça on fait de mal à personne et
puis si je suis pris je peux dire que
j'étais un ébéniste journaliste
exactement mais cache le quelque part on
cache le cache de hockey je la mets dans
la popoche comme ça très bien écoute je
crois qu'on est bons n'est parfait merci
à jean p alexis l'excellent alexei
petrov alexei petrov l'ébéniste écoute
je vais tester cinq petites minutes pour
retenir toutes ces informations là très
bien et ensuite c'est l'agent vaud qui
va être recevoir très très bien traités
merci à chanter
avec serge qui tue un homme
peut-être même un régime en entier
bonjour bonjour
c'est ici que l'interrogatoire commence
je vais poser les questions je vais
donner les réponses
du coup c'est pas
parce que l'interrogatoire de ces
questions réponses du coup je peux être
on n'a jamais géré viac
d'accord parce que je parle pas russe
je suis l'agent au comme moi vous allez
devenir agent double donc il va falloir
faire vos preuves pour ça vous allez
passer l'épreuve des mentalistes très
bien une preuve de confiance des
royautés de mémorisation
le preuve de flegme ça fait beaucoup si
vous avez aussi beaucoup ça fait
beaucoup mais vous allez le passé face
aux plus grands agents que l'agencé
connu c'est à dire moi ah d'accord ainsi
que sous l'oeil vigilant des autres
agents qui sont connectés aux diverses
caméras qui sont ici et peuvent
participer dans l'espace commentaire
très bien
noriac
je suis désolé parce que moi j'ai fait
allemand lv1 et je parle pas russe
qu'est ce que c'est à dire nos vieilles
moi je sais pas mais moi j'ai fait et
espagnol du coup je sais pas non plus
mais je trouvais que ken hicks a fait ça
fait ça fait russe un peu mais j'ai côté
russe ça veut dire ça fait un bruit
j'écoute ces cas-là place d'accords
commencé l'interrogatoire d'un yack nos
vieilles cadillac
9 les klaba tv
on se voit nos vieilles ou ce jeu
nous dit à cabourg
je dois un peu stressé un seuil dans les
entretiens comme ça n'est pas mon but
loire
au premier entretien d'agents secrets
c'est à babar ou non gm pour détendre
l'atmosphère vous avez constitué un
totem vous avez reçu des ordres de
mission ce genre de choses mon but
maintenant est de réussir à vous tutoyez
parce que je n'ai toujours pas fait mon
but maintenant agent b et de trouver des
informations que tu as dans ta tête avec
des vrais technique de mentalist pour
voir si vous êtes fiable dans la
rétention d'information dans le fait de
considérer votre esprit comme un coffre
secret parce que si les russes vous
interroge vous dire que ça va pas être
une autre affaire je suis insoutenable
on va devoir tester votre capacité de
déduction
parce que vient de dessiner
un des indes et avec des titres comme un
escargot ou des petits vieux qui chante
c'est pas mal c'est une maison ça la
forme d'indicés promettent que vous
mettez dans le centre en est sans
épargner déchantent
absolument pas par contre j'aime le fait
que vous n'abandonnez jamais je vous
mets plus un demi point merci j'aimerais
d'abord tester vos capacités de
mémorisation très bien vous avez reçu
une mission avec un numéro de mission en
chiffres et en lettres je ne le sais pas
encore est ce que vous pouvez me le
restituer comme certes de base oui je
vous écoute eu d'été eu d'été que c'est
ssh
c'est correct je commets m'embêter par
votre incapacité à avoir analysé ce code
parce que j'ai vu que vous avez eu un
problème de rétention vous avez fait des
séquences où l'avait rangé par bloc de
trois pour ménager votre mémoire de
travail s'était pas utile ce sont les
premières lettres de 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
vous auriez pu le voir à
pendant ce temps pour moi on va passer
maintenant à la grande phase de ce
projet et de cette épreuve à savoir
vérifier votre capacité à retenir une
information dans votre cerveau je vais
d'abord m'intéresser à votre toten vous
connaissent évidemment son signe
astrologique
vous êtes incollables oui
j'imagine il un problème c'est un
problème parce que face aux russes oui
il aurait jamais le temps de vérifier
ces informations
pensez à vous améliorer de ce côté là je
parle en votant pour moi par contre
j'imagine que vous connaissez sa date de
naissance tout à fait votre date de
naissance ma date de naissance date de
naissance parce que je te tutoie vous la
voulez non ne me donner plus
d'informations à partir demain soir donc
sujette à part quand je vous le demande
d'une manière franche et ouverte très
bien maintenant que je vous demande pas
de répondre ne me répondait très bien
j'imagine que c'est quelqu'un qui est né
soit dans le début de l'année soit dans
le milieu de l'année soit dans la fin de
l'année
c'est possible jusque là même pas
répondre un peu inquiétez pas votre
corps a réagi pour vous nous l'avons
constaté sur cette caméra là vous avez
fait un petit oui de la tête très franc
à peine discret sur fin d'année et ce en
se maintenant les îles oui oui et ses
petits signes d'agacement combien de
voir au niveau des lèvres dans à
confirmer imaginez que vous êtes en
interrogatoire l'espagne n'avait pas le
droit de réagir l'ennemi essaye de vous
soustraire la plantation au café il en
train de détecter que vous êtes
peut-être un agent double là c'est votre
peau vous risquez à jambes et c'est en
octobre en décembre sont des mois qui me
semble probable pour la fin d'année
surtout novembre et décembre a priori
si vous me décrire ça n'a rien à voir je
repensais à une les plaisanteries qu'on
s'était dit
l'instant je peux citer décembre qui
vous faisait marrer mais
vous êtes un livre ouvert reprenez-vous
au nom des petits tests sur le mensonge
êtes vous capable de me donner cinq
chiffres entre 1 et 31 correspondant aux
jours que l'on peut trouver dans le mois
d'une année nous est ce que vous pouvez
me donner 5 chiffre incluant le chiffre
de votre date de naissance sans rien
laisser transparaître serait bien si par
exemple vous êtes né le 1 vous pouvez
lire 1 2 3 4 5 je vais vous dire
29 5 6 2 ie8 notre
limite obligatoirement le 29 et 2,8 qui
sont aux extrêmes l'ennemi le sait le
cerveau n'aime pas les extrêmes il a
l'impression que c'est trop facile à
trouver donc vous allez vouloir le
cacher à l'intérieur pas au milieu parce
que je vous ai donné un nombre impair le
milieu remarquable donc il nous reste la
deuxième et la quatrième position
à quel moment avez-vous ralenti à quel
moment avez vous changé de rythme vous
avez fait tac tac tac tac
le quatrième n'est pas bon le quatrième
c'était le 2 ça me ferait 1 2 12
si j'ai bon jusqu'ici c'est moins bon
pour vous on vérifiera tout à l'heure il
me manque votre à des naissances est né
dans les années 1900 parce qu'ici rien
d'incroyable où je me fie à l'année
actuelle à l'âge que vous avez à priori
ce n'est pas 4 en 10 ans ou alors vous
les cachets extrêmement bien ce serait
un atout ce pas 90 dans kiss est parce
que vous connaissez votre âge actuel
fonctionne votre fausse identité
c'est un problème c'est comme pour le
signe du sagittaire il y en en quelle
année né en 1960 donc si nous sommes en
1960 je connais mon âge actuel
comme vous connaissez vraiment pas votre
signe astrologique parce que je ne vous
tendre un piège en stipulant que vous
étiez probablement sagittaire vous
n'avez pas réagi ni en bien ni en mal
effectivement sagittaire c'est celui qui
a un petit arc absolument oui d'accord
effectivement je sais pas où il se
positionne dans l'année en tout cas si
j'ai juste pour l'instant sur ce que je
pense être votre date de naissance
sachez que vous êtes serviteur c'est
probablement née entre 1915 et 1925
jambes je ne sais pas ce qu'on va faire
de vous peut-être standard liste est
encore numéro
1915 1916
1917 1918 1919
1920 1921 1922 923 924 relâchement à 23
crispation à 21
21 ou 22 ce qui explique la crispation
soit anticipée soit en amont le 23 dites
moi je ne suis pas né en 1921 je ne suis
pas né en 1921 dites moi je suis pas né
en 1922 je ne
les ai pas parlé s'il vous plaît
je ne suis pas né en 1922 à jean p je
peux vous le dire en chinois
selon la technique du de gare où vous
vous défendez vos coups trop
cet hiver très mauvais vous êtes né le 2
décembre 1922 est ce que c'est correct
là vous pouvez me répondre franchement
c'est tout à fait correct ne soyez pas
heureux d'avoir faut vous avez raté
cette première épreuve oui pardon à mes
gestes subjugué subjugué sur le 2
décembre 1922 sur toutes les dates de
l'année je suis assez subjugué ce qui
veut dire que si j'étais l'ennemi pour
fait pas grand chose avec une essence à
part à savoir quand mauvais oh ça aurait
imaginé que que l'ennemi vous confronte
et vous disent concentrez-vous sur la
première lettre de votre nom de famille
d'accord vous passeriez toutes les
lettres de votre nom de famille en revue
mentalement et puis l'ennemi pourrait
faire des signes devant vous pour
essayer de détecter les décors
g1v ouvertement est-ce que c'est correct
sur mon la première lettre de votre nom
de famille ou mais demont entre membrane
taille du vous êtes un totem
en totale non vous avez vous avez
confondu avec votre vrai nom de famille
il possède une âme et facilement il
possible que j'ai confondu club
visualiser toutes les lettres du nom de
famille de votre totem de nouveau comme
maintenant concentrez-vous sur la
dernière lettre du nom de famille comme
ça peut-être moins de danger et vous
regardez des symboles que je fais vous
imaginez que je suis en train de
dessiner dans votre sens de lecture
cette lettre qu'en faisant un petit peu
n'importe quoi pour voir ce qui marche
le mieux ou moins bien
le verrou marche vous vous êtes très
très con aussi un v
va pas être con donc c'est un but c'est
que j'ai eu peur
c'est fort vous avez un métier également
beau pratiquer un métier un métier que
vous avez choisi vous même est ce que
vous pourriez vous imaginer réaliser
vraiment ce métier oui à partir de
maintenant ce sont des questions à
laquelle fne besoin d'aucune réponse
physique ou verbale c'est important vous
résistez à l'interrogatoire ça peut être
un métier bureaucratique derrière un
bureau
ça peut être un métier ayant besoin
d'une action physique provenant de vous
ça peut être un métier plus intellectuel
nécessitant beaucoup de ressources ça
peut être un métier lié à la politique
est un métier créatif ça peut être un
métier
demandant des efforts artisanaux
peut-être
mais donc vous soyez en train de faire
votre métier il ya une partie de votre
corps qui est en train de fonctionner
pour faire ce métier ne fonctionne plus
que les autres
ça peut être un métiers
d'artisanat quotidien où ça peut être
quelque chose de plus fonctionnel les
électriciens
pompiers un métier vous allez changer
peut-être la phase
2 de l'architecturé d'un bâtiment
peut-être quelque chose de plus
minutieux quelque chose de plus
minutieux quelque chose qui va qui va
transformer de la matière qui le matière
de les transformer qu'est-ce qu'on peut
transformer le transformer pour le métal
l'argile
voyez pas menuisiers des fois je vais
vous demander une réponse ouverte
très bien vous m'avez bluffer pour la
première fois la jambe et quel était
votre métier
vous étiez très très proche des choisi
ébéniste progrès saint servais coup je
serai pas tout à fait capable de bien
exprimer les différences entre les deux
l'honnêteté de l'agent double que je
suis m'oblige à dire que je suis bluffé
le som oblige à lire que franchement
menuisier ébéniste mais je
tacle bois mais techniquement vous avez
fait preuve d'une quand même résistance
beaucoup plus correct que depuis le
début de cet entretien
je suis une statue de bronze maintenant
comment réagiriez-vous peut-être avec un
petit peu plus de pression je vous narre
les plusieurs fois quel est votre nom de
famille et vous devez jamais me répondre
aucune famille de totem comment vous
appelez-vous
comment est-ce que c'est aussi un nom de
famille long c'est court c'est long ça
finit par un v quand vous appelez
comment vous vous appelez essayé de me
le dire me le dit pas prononcé le sans
le dire vous appelez vos lèvres elle
travaille cdu labiale mbp mbp
pppp quelque chose fait quelque chose
vous êtes russe petras maîtrise et trop
petrov petrov petrov petrov petrov né le
2 décembre 1922 menuisier ébéniste et la
même chose on retrouvera voyez comment
vous faites des matches qui a rapidement
je me sens m là
quand j'avais travaillé vous êtes déçu
un peu mais je suis déçu de moi-même
parce que je pensais faire une belle
paire j'étais arrivé sur un nom de
famille plutôt courts qui se connaît pas
trop sur l'échelle de tous les chats les
russes ouais mais en même temps je ne
parle même pas je me fais avoir certes
je parle même pas on tique vous que les
agents russes sont aussi compétents que
moi c'est moi qui les ai formé à
l'époque ok c'est pour ça que je fais un
genou pour essayer de m'en acheter il me
reste une chose à travailler sur vont
piquer votre histoire vous avez dû
sélectionner l'un des gadgets mis à
votre disposition
pour venir mais pour partir en mission
je suis entre plusieurs objets fait vous
demander de penser à l'endroit où ça se
trouve actuellement précisément sur
votre corps ça peut être même sous votre
siège ou sous vous directement ou cachés
dans votre dos fait dans une poche
intérieure extérieure ça peut être un
petit peu partout je vais pointer
maintenant du doigt exactement l'endroit
où se trouve cet objet si les sous la
table on imaginera que mon doigt tel un
faisceau laser traverse la table
imaginez que je suis un agent russe que
si je trouve cet objet c'est
définitivement condamné réagissez à ce
stress regardez mon doit
résister à l envie de tirer dessus
ce n'est pas un objet caché là juste
juste là à ce niveau ici
si je fouille ici je vais trouver quoi
je vais trouver peut-être un livre et
vous seriez très malin parce que je sais
pas comment vous l'auriez fait rentrer
donc j'ai trouvé le plus probablement un
briquet
un stylo
les pièces de monnaie
sortez l'objet que vous avez dans votre
poche ici s'il vous plaît faites-le
vraiment
un stylo
je vois mal ni j'écris très mal d'accord
mais où que ce soit juste pour avec leur
parution ces stylos
démasquage que je pense pas encore vous
ceux liés à ces résistants sauf si
peut-être vous excellez dans l'art de
résister aux manipulations et aux
influences à saché genre de choix au
rachat or qu'est-ce que oui
je vous demandais s'il vous plaît de me
dire sans réfléchir
quand je te l'a créé des doigts
uniquement et sans réfléchir vous me
donnerez s'il vous plaît sans réfléchir
quand je claqué des doigts un outil une
couleur une musique maintenant
partout rouge avait que du rap marteau
rouge rap
d'être fiers de vous pourra plus que ça
c'est un solide et une tchèque une
couleur musicale agents plm chercher ce
que j'ai laissée dans la voiture nos
biens
[Musique]
un art au rouge et or a
sorti comme ça réfléchissez un petit peu
mieux tout ce qui s'est passé lorsque
vous êtes arrivé ici à l'entrepôt des
familles une jeune femme passait devant
vous près de la voiture avec un sac à
main ancien qu'est ce qui dépassait de
son sac à main je ne peux pas vous le
dire un marteau
parce que vous n'avez pas vu dans la
voiture des éléments rouge qui ont
attiré votre regard tout au long de
votre trajet peut-être les sièges
complètement rouge parce que vous êtes
certain de ne pas avoir entendu de
musique qui n'existe pas dans les années
60 là où nous nous trouvons actuellement
peut-être qu'elle soit 0 cher êtes vous
certain de ne pas avoir entendu
plusieurs fois durables depuis que vous
êtes arrivé ici non vous avez diffusé
une
santé sur de goûts
étant pas très influençable je dirais
oui par exemple là j'en fais tout à
l'heure vous a confié une enveloppe vous
l'avez toujours je lai seconde s'il vous
plaît
donnez à chanter j'ai dans ma poche
je suis dessinateur c'est bien ça ça
vous dit rien ça
année oui son rétroviseur il met un
satin rouge complément votre blog s'il
vous plaît
avez vous résistez à la tentation de
l'ouvrir bien sûr agents où avez vous lu
le papier qui se trouve à l'intérieur
non découvrons le ensemble
l'ouverture des plis
marteau rouge rap
à la je suis
définitivement
vous n'êtes pas prêt à prendre le risque
de mettre votre vie en jeu en russie 1
jambes et
vous retourner en formation je vous
reverrai jamais bon c est le pire agents
que j'aie jamais rencontré ses pas ayant
enfin merci à dieu ya jamais berbiac
aujourd'hui sur les plats trop déçu
quand même vous savez l'influent ce
n'est pas un critère d'élimination je
savais que j'étais influencé à appeler
quelqu'un qui a réussi à refourguer ce
costume quand même
et quand même ne vous fiez pas vos
intuitions ah oui d'accord mais tu es
tout en doute tout le temps vous allez
passer aux modules de la formation très
bien c'est en quelque sorte une
formation de rattrapage mais j'y mets
mombris qui va vous apprendre mieux
tenir votre peau thèmes et ne pas vous
laissez influencer très bien quand on
est un jour en jour on est agent
toujours toujours toujours toujours
toujours réputé quand on est agent un
jour on dit
c'est pas parce qu'on est un agent
toujours qu'on ait peur qu'on n'est pas
agent toujours bon quand on est l'agent
un jour on est on peut être agent pour
trop de jeu pour toujours pour tous les
jours puisque leur un jour c'est c'est
demain demain je peux être agent c'est
pas aujourd'hui mais pour toujours mais
du coup voilà c'est incroyable j'avais
depuis le début dans la poche donc ce
que j'ai vu là bas puis vous venez de
naissage en paix depuis le début dans la
poche j'ai des mots que je vais dire une
demi-heure après sous influence
inconsciente ou pas je ne sais pas et
c'est incroyable on va peut-être la
formation je peux changer de costume
bien sûr ainsi beaucoup on attaque la
formation à temps d'une demi heure
merci encore après une vidéo de nous
avoir donné l'opportunité de produire
une vidéo comme celle ci comme promis
voici la bande annonce de la série totem
que vous pouvez retrouver dès à présent
surprême vidéo
le nombre de rapports sur la conquête de
l'espace un triplé en deux ans nous
avons besoin de tourner expertise ce
qu'est le sujet
ça concerne un projet spatial russe
c'est moi qui vous fera passer la
frontière c'est un document top secret
je suis prise pour
une mission en allemagne je lui ai dit
quoi
tu es libre à l'antre
d'un autre côté on se connaît plus
cible et radagast
- devant un magasin
sa fille
si vous voulez le parler à nouveau je
peux vous aider
je n'ai jamais l'occasion de parler avec
un fond c
est celle qui fait du doigt
pourquoi il des
études pour ce qu'on peut lui faire
confiance
trêve de vivre en france je peux vous
aider le prince et en conséquence je
peux attaquer nos professeurs nous avons
très peu de temps
l'urss est un projet bon morby talent
capables de contourner tous les systèmes
de défense et ses lots distincts le
guidage qu'ils utilisent
cette bombe n'est pas qu'un projet elle
est déjà en orbite a
[Musique]
dit pas si le kgb les coudes on ne peut
plus continuer avec elle
[Musique]
et c'est à tout le monde
totem le 18 février exclusivement sur
prime vidéo
j'espère que ces quelques secondes on
susciter votre intérêt n'hésitez pas
parce que vraiment ça en vaut la peine
si vous voulez découvrir la série totem
toutes les infos sont dans le lien dans
la description comme d'habitude c'est
très facile merci encore mille fois
benjamin verica de s'être rendus
disponibles pour ce faire mentaliser
aujourd'hui si la vidéo vous a plu comme
d'habitude vous pouvez lalique et vous
pouvez partager dans les commentaires ce
que vous vous aviez trouvé dans les
trucs qu'il avait dans sa tête et puis
vous pouvez vous abonner activer la
cloche moi je m'appelle toujours fabien
olicard quand je suis pas agent double
évidemment prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt ciao bresse des épisodes à
regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]